Trascrizione: claudia vettore
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Voi ve lo siete certamente chiesti,
ma vi confesso
che lo sono chiesto anch'io:
che ci azzecca l'empatia
con la politica internazionale?
Che ci azzecca in un mondo di conflitti -
Libia, Yemen, Iran in questo momento,
Israele e Palestina, Trump con Huawei,
Trump con l'Iran, Trump con la Cina -
che ci azzecca in questo mondo l'empatia,
cioè la capacità di mettersi
nei panni degli altri,
la capacità di accettare
che rispetto a uno stesso fatto,
uno stesso fenomeno,
qualcun altro, un'altra persona
lo legga in modo diverso,
lo veda in modo diverso,
e quel modo di leggerlo, di guardarlo
è legittimo, devo considerarlo,
devo tenerne conto?
Che spazio ha - vi sarete chiesti -
in un mondo di questo tipo l'empatia?
Che spazio ha, in un mondo
dove la lettura prevalente
nelle teorie della politica internazionale
è che le relazioni fra Stati,
come quelle fra gli uomini,
sono regolati dall' "Homo Homini Lupus",
dalla logica di prevalenza,
di prevaricazione,
dall'interesse, dalla forza, dal potere -
tutto l'opposto del mettersi
nei panni degli altri,
tutto l'opposto dell'accettare
che altri vedano in modo diverso.
E in questo mondo la prima lettura -
e da qui la domanda, "Che ci azzecca?" -
è che questa visione un po' romantica,
quasi ottimista dell'empatia,
che può o potrebbe, dovrebbe avere
un ruolo nella politica internazionale
ci pare molto lontana.
Un mondo dove accettiamo gli altri,
accettiamo il loro punto di vista,
ci vogliamo tutti bene
e tutti vissero felici e contenti
è molto lontano dall'esperienza
della nostra vita quotidiana,
è molto lontano dalla realtà.
E quindi una frase come quella di Obama,
quando incontra il Papa e gli dice:
"È la mancanza di empatia che ci sta
facendo scivolare nella guerra",
ci sembra una speranza,
un'espressione di ottimismo, di illusione,
ma non sicuramente qualcosa
che vediamo nei fatti.
Così come un'altra frase
di un sociologo americano, Rifkin,
che dice che solo attraverso
l'empatia globale,
l'empatia fra tutto il mondo,
riusciremo ad affrontare
tutte le cose brutte del mondo:
la crisi economica,
il degrado ambientale, le guerre.
Ma Obama con il Papa,
e Rifkin in questa frase,
sono degli inguaribili ottimisti,
dei visionari, degli illusi
o nell'empatia realmente c'è
la panacea, la soluzione,
un modo per affrontare
problemi del nostro mondo,
che non va nella direzione giusta?
Cerchiamo di muoverci
fra questi due estremi:
l'empatia come soluzione a tutto
e l'empatia - come direbbero i realisti -
come qualcosa di inutile,
perché nel mondo governano la forza,
la supremazia e l'aggressività.
Sicuramente possiamo dire
che l'aspirazione all'empatia,
a mettersi nei panni degli altri,
è un tratto che sempre c'è
nei rapporti fra Stati.
Voi avrete visto queste immagini -
buffe, ci fanno sorridere:
sono i vertici del G20,
o i vertici dell'Europa
con i paesi asiatici
o l'Europa con i paesi africani.
E vediamo questi leader del mondo -
qui c'è Putin con Bush,
è un'immagine di anni fa -
in questi buffi abiti.
Perché lo fanno?
Lo fanno perché si mettono, letteralmente,
nei panni degli altri,
nei panni del paese che li ospita.
È un modo simbolico per dire:
sposo la tua cultura, sono come te,
cerco di essere come te.
Un fatto simbolico
che vediamo in tante occasioni.
Ma il provare a mettersi
nei panni degli altri
e il provare ad accettare,
di uno stesso fenomeno,
una lettura diversa
aiuta, aiuterebbe, sarebbe
molto utile in molte crisi.
Ve ne cito brevemente alcune.
Partiamo dall'Iran:
voi tutti sapete che l'Iran
è da decenni in una situazione difficile,
e ha creato situazioni difficili.
Dalla rivoluzione, poi il tentativo
di avere il nucleare,
l'accordo di Obama con l'Iran;
e poi dopo arriva Trump,
che cancella l'accordo,
e ora ci sono sull'Iran venti di guerra.
Americani e iraniani potrebbero -
nessuno lo auspica -
arrivare di nuovo a un forte confronto.
Facciamo insieme l'esercizio di empatia,
cioè di provare a vedere
dal punto di vista dell'altro
la situazione in questa crisi.
Provate per un secondo a essere iraniani.
Siete iraniani, e siete
in quel paese rosso circondato dal blu.
Quel paese rosso è l'Iran, un paese sciita
che ha un certo sistema di governo -
che non ci piace, che non è
democratico come lo vorremmo,
ma è un paese sciita circondato dal blu,
che sono paesi sunniti ostili.
L'Iran è ostile al blu,
i blu sono ostili al rosso.
E in questi paesi ostili -
fra questi paesi ostili
alcuni non sono sunniti,
Israele non è sicuramente
un paese islamico -
alcuni di questi paesi -
il Pakistan, sotto l'India, Israele -
hanno la bomba atomica
e sono in tensione con l'Iran.
E fra questi paesi ce n'è uno:
l'arcinemico, l'Arabia Saudita;
e questo paese, l'Arabia Saudita,
da quando c'è Trump al potere,
è diventato il miglior amico
dell'America insieme a Israele,
cioè i due nemici dell'Iran
sono i migliori amici dell'America.
Se voi foste iraniani,
vedreste la crescita del nucleare -
cioè avere anche voi una bomba nucleare -
come la migliore assicurazione per la vita
in quel contesto molto difficile.
Provate adesso a fare l'americano,
a provare a mettervi
nel punto di vista di un americano.
Un americano di 50 anni o di 45 anni,
quando era bambino vedeva ogni giorno
le immagini dei dipendenti
dell'ambasciata americana
tenuti prigionieri in Iran.
E tutti i giorni si parlava di quello:
quindi gli iraniani sono quelli
che rapiscono i miei colleghi,
il papà del mio amico,
i soldati che sono lì.
Se io guardo negli Stati Uniti
la televisione Fox News,
ogni volta che si parla di Iran,
anche per parlare di un terremoto in Iran,
fanno vedere le immagini di repertorio
delle bandiere americane bruciate
dell'epoca di Ahmadinejad;
e io sono americano,
e vedo un paese, un popolo
che distrugge, incendia la mia bandiera.
E se poi vado su Netflix
e vedo Homeland, una di queste serie,
lì il nemico degli Americani,
che vuole uccidere
il presidente americano,
vuole uccidere tutti i deputati,
è l'Iran.
Viene presentato l'Iran, anche,
come il colpevole dell'attentato
delle Torri Gemelle
che in realtà era stato fatto
da persone legate all'Arabia Saudita -
pensate voi, l'Arabia Saudita
e l'Iran sono nemici, ma lì -
Quindi: io americano cresco ad anti-Iran;
io iraniano cresco col timore;
allora, in questo contesto,
si arriva all'escalation,
che può portare al confronto.
L'empatia è quella che ha esercitato
per un breve periodo Obama,
cercando invece di trovare un accordo,
per dire quali sono le ragioni dell'Iran,
quali sono le nostre ragioni.
Ma fate lo stesso con la questione Russia:
la Russia invade la Crimea,
qualche anno fa.
Fatto gravissimo,
rompe una regola del mondo;
ma cerchiamo di capire -
non giustificare -
le ragioni della Russia.
La Russia nel 1990 era circondata -
guardate la parte centrale,
dove c'è Ungheria, Polonia, Bulgaria -
tutto il suo confine
era fatto di paesi alleati,
erano nel Patto di Varsavia, tutti amici.
Un po' alla volta quei paesi -
guardate questa slide -
sono diventati tutti blu,
perché sono diventati l'Ungheria,
la Polonia, la Bulgaria, paesi europei:
una volta entrati nell'Europa,
sono diventati paesi Nato.
E la Nato è nata
per contrapporsi alla Russia.
Dal punto di vista russo, quindi,
si sente circondata
e l'unico paese che manca
è quello azzurro.
Qual è il paese azzurro?
L'Ucraina.
E l'Ucraina che cosa fa, tre anni fa?
Decide di guardare all'Europa,
di chiedere di entrare in Europa.
E qual è il film che si fa la Russia?
Se entra in Europa,
fra un anno sono nella Nato
e io sono circondata da blu,
sono accerchiata;
e quindi, dal punto di vista russo
quello era l'unico modo -
non giustificabile, scorretto -
per mantenere un proprio interesse
e salvaguardarlo.
Ma pensate se ci fosse empatia
nella Brexit -
prima si è parlato di Brexit.
Il disastro della Brexit,
che sembra un Gioco dell'Oca,
è la dimostrazione della incapacità
di tutti gli inglesi, in Gran Bretagna,
di capire le ragioni dell'altro:
quelli che vogliono uscire
non capiscono le ragioni
di quelli che vogliono rimanere,
il governo non capisce le ragioni
di quelli dell'Europa:
vuole cose impossibili,
ma non capisce che l'Europa
non può dare le condizioni
che la Gran Bretagna sta chiedendo;
la May non riesce a mettersi
nei panni, neanche,
dei suoi parlamentari conservatori,
metà dei quali vogliono uscire,
metà dei quali vogliono rimanere;
e soprattutto, il governo di Londra
non riesce a capire
le frustrazioni, i drammi, le ragioni
degli scozzesi o degli irlandesi,
che dopo la Brexit
avrebbero problemi ulteriori.
E quindi, il risultato
è che c'è un Gioco dell'Oca impazzito
perché nessuno è in grado di porsi
nei panni dell'altro
e trovare la mediazione,
il punto d'incontro.
Ma c'è un esempio dove capiamo
quanto fu importante a un certo punto,
da parte di qualcuno,
uscire dalla fretta della lettura veloce
e mettersi nei panni degli altri.
Alcuni di voi lo ricorderanno:
nel 1983, un aereo coreano
passa - per sbaglio, lo sappiamo dopo -
sul territorio russo.
Siamo in piena Guerra Fredda,
grandi tensioni,
c'era Reagan che parlava
di Guerre Stellari,
della Russia come Impero del Male.
I russi lo vedono arrivare, lo abbattono:
è un aereo passeggeri
con 269 persone a bordo.
Immediatamente, gli americani
reagiscono con grande forza,
perché i russi non dicono neanche
quello che è successo,
negano l'incidente.
Gli americani reagiscono,
organizzano un'esercitazione Nato
entro due mesi, molto potente;
i russi vedono questa esercitazione Nato
come un attacco alla Russia;
danno l'ordine di preparare
le rampe di lancio dei missili nucleari;
e si sfiora come a Cuba,
20 anni prima, una guerra nucleare.
Perché dico che l'empatia qua è servita?
Perché lo sappiamo ora, anni dopo,
che fu la capacità di capire
come stavano leggendo i fenomeni
altri che usarono le spie,
i servizi segreti inglesi
a fermare questo grande dramma
che stava accadendo.
In che senso?
Gli inglesi si resero conto che non c'era,
da parte dei russi, cattiva volontà.
Non volevano abbattere un aereo
per far partire una guerra:
avevano sbagliato.
Avevano sbagliato
perché l'Unione Sovietica
stava già entrando in crisi,
c'erano pochissimi soldi,
i radar non funzionavano,
quindi quell'aereo è apparso
sul territorio russo all'ultimo momento
ed è apparso in uno spazio
del territorio russo,
dove c'è una base di lancio
di missili russi di prova;
e quindi i russi han detto:
sta arrivando un aereo, sta arrivando
proprio dove noi abbiamo
una base di lancio
e la lunga catena di comando
della gerarchia russa
lancia dei messaggi che vanno dal capitano
che scrive al colonnello
e il colonnello al generale,
arrivano fino a Mosca.
A Mosca Andropov, il presidente,
è malato, è in ospedale:
c'è un po' di caos.
Danno l'ordine di sparare,
e poi, come in tutte le dittature,
coprono tutto per cinque giorni.
Tutto ciò, al momento,
perché non c'era la volontà e la capacità
di mettersi nel punto di vista dell'altro,
il punto di vista di una dittatura
alla fine della sua storia
sembrava portare
a una lettura sbagliatissima:
i russi stanno attaccando l'Occidente.
E furono gli inglesi
dei Servizi Segreti della Thatcher
che corsero da Reagan dicendo:
non stiamo capendo niente!
Hanno fatto un errore,
non hanno il coraggio di ammetterlo:
fermiamo tutto.
E questa è l'empatia, quindi, che aiuta;
e soprattutto l'empatia -
cioè la capacità di mettersi
nei panni degli altri -
che è una condizione fondamentale
per un aspetto cruciale del nostro mondo,
in questo momento in grande crisi:
il multilateralismo,
cioè il condominio del mondo cioè l'ONU.
La precondizione per lavorare dentro l'ONU
è che io accetto
che anche lo Stato più piccolo del mondo,
che non ha nessun potere,
né economico né militare,
ha una sua ragione,
una sua ragione d'essere.
Quando l'ONU è nato,
è partito da quel principio,
riconoscendo che gli Stati più importanti
sono più potenti ovviamente -
il Consiglio di Sicurezza,
il diritto di veto -
ma accettando che il condominio del mondo
deve tenere un po' conto anche di tutti.
E senza ONU, senza condominio del mondo,
noi non siamo in grado
di affrontare i problemi globali:
il clima, le migrazioni, il terrorismo.
Problemi che, se uno Stato
li affronta da solo,
può tamponare ma non li risolve.
Pensate alle migrazioni.
Le migrazioni hanno:
paesi di origine; paesi di transito;
e paesi di destinazione.
I paesi di origine
sono contenti se i migranti vanno:
meno disoccupati
e gente che manda le rimesse,
quindi mi dà ricchezza,
hanno tutto l'interesse a incentivarlo.
I paesi di transito, come il Ciad,
sono paesi che prosperano
sul traffico dei migranti:
arrivano, mangiano, dormono,
chiedono i passaggi con i pulmini -
la mia popolazione vive su quello.
I paesi di destinazione -
noi siamo fra questi -
non li vogliono, non li vogliono più,
li vorrebbero selezionare.
Quindi hanno obiettivi
totalmente diversi fra di loro.
Ma se non si trova un qualche minimo
comune denominatore,
cercando di capire le ragioni dell'altro,
non si andrà lontano.
Noi andiamo dai paesi africani a dire:
"Ti do mezzo milione, un milione di euro
per aiutarti a casa tua":
ma se non ragiono nella mente
del presidente di quel paese,
che se i migranti escono, di milioni
ne mandano casa 75 con le rimesse,
quel presidente mi dirà:
"Sì, certo, va bene, senz'altro";
ma non farà nulla, perché c'è
una logica totalmente diversa.
Quali sono le conclusioni?
Siamo partiti dall'empatia -
che ci azzecca?
L'empatia dove la vediamo,
in questo mondo, dov'è?
Guardando il mondo, il mondo reale,
chi mi dice che l'empatia
è la soluzione di tutto
vive su un altro mondo.
C'è un pendolo
fra chi crede che l'empatia
è una pia illusione
e chi crede che l'empatia
è la panacea, la soluzione di tutto.
Su che cosa possiamo provare
a trovare un accordo?
L'empatia è una condizione necessaria,
per aiutare il mondo a fare meno pasticci,
ma non è sufficiente.
C'è l'empatia, serve l'empatia,
ma sempre ci governeranno,
avranno importanza
gli interessi, la supremazia e la forza;
ma l'empatia è appunto
una condizione necessaria,
anche se non sufficiente.
E come la coltivo l'empatia
e come la distruggo l'empatia,
senza esaltarla, ma pensando
che possa servire?
Come la coltivo?
La coltivo innanzitutto conoscendo,
studiando, con la curiosità,
di conoscere gli altri paesi,
le loro culture, le loro abitudini,
viaggiando, conoscendo,
intrigandomi degli altri,
di ciò che è diverso,
accettando il cibo, i costumi -
non chiudendomi sulla pasta alla Norma
rispetto al risotto alla milanese,
ma accettando anche realtà diverse.
Quindi, il primo [modo] è la curiosità.
Il secondo modo per coltivare l'empatia
è passare dai numeri,
dalle masse, ai singoli.
Tutti noi abbiamo conosciuto
il dramma dell'Olocausto,
ma i milioni ci dicono poco,
ci hanno detto poco
finché non abbiamo conosciuto
la storia, e le vicende,
della famiglia di Anna Frank.
Tutti noi conosciamo
il dramma delle migrazioni,
ma sono numeri fino a quando non vediamo
l'immagine del piccolo Aylan
sulle coste della Grecia
e lì capiamo che potrebbe essere
un bambino come nostro nipote,
come nostro figlio,
come il figlio dei nostri amici.
Quindi il passare, come dice Madre Teresa,
dalle masse all'individuo
è il modo per passare dal grigio, dal buio
all'empatia per le singole persone.
E come si distrugge, invece, l'empatia?
L'empatia si distrugge
quando generalizziamo,
l'empatia si distrugge quando diciamo:
"Negri", "islamici radicalizzati", "froci"
quando usiamo termini che cercano di dare
a delle comunità anche vastissime
un'etichetta generale e complessiva.
Come si distrugge l'empatia?
Si distrugge quando esagero
nel sottolineare l'importanza
del me, dell'io, dell'identità nazionale,
dell'identità, delle tradizioni,
delle culture, delle radici,
le mie, "my country first".
Questo, che crea un noi
e un loro a prescindere
è un passaggio per distruggere l'empatia.
L'empatia la creiamo
quando cominciamo a dire:
sì, i neri, i migranti sono un problema;
però io conosco quello
della bancarella lì, è un bravo ragazzo;
e cambio atteggiamento.
Quando dico: la religione musulmana
è diversa da noi, è un problema,
però quello della bancarella
in fondo che vende le borsette
lo conosco da dieci anni,
è un bravo ragazzo.
Quando entriamo un po' alla volta,
senza appiattirci sull'altro -
nessuno vuole questo -
ma a capire che l'altro
non è bianco e nero,
ma c'è una zona grigia -
lì siamo sulla buona strada.
Grazie.
(Applausi)